[Music]
before the reboot that will keep the
characters out of Marvel's hands but
after the Roger Corman movie that also
kept the characters out of Marvel's
hands come to other attempts at the
franchise that prove these characters
should really be in Marvel's hands by
now Fantastic Four and it's crappy
sequel at a time when comic book movies
began to show how good they could be two
films will remind us how badly they can
suck you guys look like an 80s rock band
as the director of barbershop has handed
the reins of Marvel's original super
team then steers it off a cliff
and don't tell me there's no way to make
a good Fantastic Four movie it's called
The Incredibles and it's perfect with
some more or less faithful adaptation of
the totally bananas 1961 origin story
where a space cloud gives four people
completely different superpowers leading
to one movie about recreating the space
cloud on earth and one movie about
trying to save the world from a
completely different space cloud by
people called it Galactus no this is
collect Asst that is a space cloud what
is it with this air and evil clouds
stop making cloud base villains me the
Fantastic Four
whose powers line up perfectly with
their Fantastic Four shadowy family aid
always stretching my see you're still
doing all the heavy lifting to be seen
oh you're hot thank you sir there's read
the nerd Richards his crush su the girl
storm
Johnny the human chlamydia storm were
you just waiting outside the bathroom to
try and catch me in themselves and their
overly attached friend Ben the thing
Grimm who's rewarded for his loyalty by
getting they fun of literally getting
dumped on made it to an outcast I'll
take the stairs
and getting rejected by his fiancee just
for looking different man I didn't think
I could hate Andrea from the walking
dead any more than I already did
together each of the Fantastic Four must
set aside their only character trait to
take on Victor the Green Goblin Von Doom
and the silver t1000 Morpheus all the to
know is that an end but instead of the
wild space battles and psychedelic
showdowns you loved from the comics
watch them use their superpowers and a
bunch of super boring settings like
taking up overhead compartment space X
Games a dance battles PEP and skincare
I've got is it so before you see the
third and hopefully final attempt to
launch the Fantastic Four relive the
original two disappointments who gave
their lives so that Chris Evans could be
free to play a decent Captain America
sorry I violin you on e one gruff a
funded starring island group of foot ah
not again has too many vowels and too
many consonants Ilan mask Mercury Rising
battle cloud Galactica's Jessica Alba's
a rotting pumpkin scandalous and cap
torch America craptastic bore make a
Mexican woman put on a blonde wig and
blue contacts to play Sue Storm and no
one bats an eye cast a black eye is the
Human Torch and everyone loses their
minds be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers
I have come here to chew bubblegum and
kick ass and I'm all out of bubblegum
either put on these glasses or start
eating that trash can it's clobbering
time
flame on I like trains choo choo bubbles
I love love love fungus I don't need an
Iron Man suit I'm already a weapon of
mass deduction